hello my antagonist in the skip are you
going to illuminate some flaw in my
Logic No actually I'm going to use you
to mock a common issue I find in online
comedy oh cool what are you looking at
you silly no you're facing the direction
that I'm facing it creates confusion
it's spatially disoriented there better
yes but wait why aren't you looking at
me I am no our eyelines aren't meeting
it's become obvious that we're one
person pretending to be two isn't that
what we are yeah but I'd like to
maintain the illusion if only briefly
that we are two separate people
occupying one space sounds like you're a
little too hung up on these things
sounds like you watched a video essay on
Hitchcock once okay you got me but you
should only break the 180° rule with
purpose and for good reason so I'm not
important enough to you hold on that's
not what I
said